و على قد
المطلب مع
[Silence]
السرح
‏fr
[Silence]
الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله حي على
الصلاه حي على الفلاح قد قامت الصلاه قد
قامت
الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله استقيموا اعتدلوا
استووا سووا الصف سدوا
الخلل
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
ولو اننا نزلنا اليهم
الملائكه
وكلمهم
الموتى
وكلمهم الموتى وحشرنا عليهم من كل شيء
قبلا وحشرنا
عليه كل شيء
قبلا ما كان
ليؤمنوا الا ان يشاء
الله
ولكن اكثرهم
يجهلون وحشرنا
عليهم وحشرنا عليهم كل شيء
قبلا ما كانوا
ليؤمنوا ما كانوا ليؤمنوا الا ان يشاء
الله لكن اكثرهم
يجهلون وكذلك جعلنا لكل نبي عدوا شياطين
الانس والجن يوحي
بعضهم يوحي بعضهم الى بعض زخرف القول
غرورا ولو شاء ربك ما فعلوه فذرهم وما يفت
ولتصغى اليه افئده الذين لا يؤمنون
بالاخره وليرضوه
وليقترفوا ما هم
مقترفون اغير الله ابتغي حكما وهو الذي
انزل اليكم الكتاب
مفصلا افغير الله ابتغي حكما وهو الذي
مفصلا والذين
اتيناهم الكتاب يعلمون انه
منزل والذين اتيناهم الكتاب يعلمون انه
منزل من ربك
بالحق فلا
تكونن من
تريم
وتمت كلمه ربك
صدقا وعدلا لا مبدل
لكلماته لا مبدل
لكلماته وهو السميع
العليم وان تطع اكثر من في الارض يضلوك عن
سبيل
الله ان يتبعون الا
الظن وان هم الا
يخرصون
ان ربك هو اعلم من يضل عن سبيله وهو اعلم
بالمهتدين
فكلوا مما ذكر اسم الله
عليه
ان
كنتم
باياته
مؤمنين ما لكم لا تاكلوا مما ذكر اسم الله
عليه وقد فصل لكم ما حرم
عليكم وقد فصل لكم ما حرم عليكم الا ما
اضطررتم
اليه وما لكم الا تاكلوا
منما لم يذكر اسم الله
عليه
وما لكم الا تاكلوا مما ذكر اسم الله عليه
وقد فصل لكم ما حرم
عليكم وقد فصل لكم ما حرم عليكم الا ما
اضطررتم
اليه
وان كثيرا ليضلون
باهوائهم
بغير
ان ربك اعلم ان ربك هو اعلم بالمعتدين
وذروا ظاهر الاثم
وباطنه ان الذين يكسبون الاثم سيجزون بما
كانوا
يقترفون ولا تاكلوا مما لم يذكر اسم الله
عليه
وانه لفسق
وان
الذين وان الشياطين ليوحون الى
اوليائهم ليجادلوكم
وان اطعتموهم
انكم
لمشركون الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد وايا ك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
ا كان م
فاحييناه وجعلنا له نورا يمشي به في
الناس وجعلنا له نورا يمشي به في الناس
ككم مثله في
الظلمات كمن مثله في الظلمات ليس
بخارج منها كذلك زين
للكافرين ما كانوا
يعملون وكذلك جعلنا في كل قريه اكابر
مجرميها ليمكروا
فيها وما يمكرون الا
بانفسهم وما
يشعرون واذا
جاءتهم ايه قالوا لن نؤمن قالوا لن نؤمن
حتى نؤتى مثل ما اوتي رسول
الله الله اعلم حيث يجعل
رسالته سيصيب الذين اجرموا صغار عند الله
وعذاب شديد بما كانوا
يمكرون فمن يرد الله ان يهديه يشرح صدره
للاسلام ومن يرد ان يضله يجعل صدره ضيقا
حرجا يجعل صدره ضيقا
حرجا
كانما يصعد في
السماء كذلك يجعل الله الرجس على الذين لا
يؤمنون
وهذا صراط ربك
مستقيما قد فصلنا الايات
لقوم
يذكرون لهم دار السلام عند ربهم وهو
وليهم وهو
وليهم بما كانوا
يعملون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله اكبر بسم
الله اياك
ن
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
سبحان الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
‏st
‏eh
[Silence]
‏qu
حا
[Silence]
‏och
‏var
[Silence]
‏w
‏k
[Silence]
تكبر
يلا
استقيموا اعتدلوا
استووا
الصف
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
ويوم يحشرهم جميعا يا معشر الجن قد
استكثرتم من الانس وقال
اولياؤهم من الانس ربنا استمتع بعضنا ببعض
وبلغنا وبلغنا اجلنا الذي اجلت لنا قال
النار مثواكم خالدين فيها الا ما شا
الله ان ربك حكيم
عليم وكذلك ني بعض الظالمين بعضا بما
كانوا
يكسبون يا معشر الجن
والانس الم ياتكم رسل منكم يقصون عليكم
اياتي يقصون عليكم اياتي و وينذرونكم
لقاء يومكم
هذا قالوا شهدنا على انفسنا وغرتهم الحياه
الدنيا وشهدوا على انفسهم انهم كانوا
كافرين ذلك ان لم يكن ربك مهلك القرى بظلم
واهلها
غافلون ولكل درج
مما
عملوا وما ربك بغافل
عما
يعملون وربك الغني ذو الرحمه ان يشا
يذهبكم ويستخلف من بعدكم ما
يشاء كما
انساكم من ذريه قوم
اخرين
انما توعدون لات وما انتم
بمعجزين قل يا قوم اعملوا على مكانتكم اني
عامل فسوف تعلمون من تكون له عاقبه الدار
انه لا يفلح
الظالمون واجعلوا لله ما ذرا من الحرف
والانعام
نصيبا فقالوا هذا لله بزعمهم وهذا
لشركائنا فما كان
لشركائهم فلا يصل الى الله وما كان لله
فهو يصل الى
شركائهم
ساء ما يحكم
وكذلك زين
لكثير من المشركين قتل اولادهم
شركاؤهم
ليردوهم ليردوهم وليلبسوا عليهم
دينهم ولو
شاء الله ما فعلوه فذرهم وما
يفترون وقالوا هذه انعام حرث حجر لا
يطعمها لا يطعمها الا من
نشاء بزعمهم وانعام حرمت عليهم ظه وانعام
حرمت
ظهورها وانعام لا يذكرون اسم الله عليها
افتراء عليه سيجزيهم
بما كانوا
يفترون وقالوا ما في بطون هذه الانعام
خالصه لذكورنا و محرم على
ازواجنا وان يكن
ميته فهم فيه
شركاء سيجزيهم
وصفهم انه حكيم
عليم قد خسر الذين قتلوا اولادهم سفها
بغير علم
وحرموه وحرموا ما رزقهم الله
افتراء على
الله قد ضلوا قد ضلوا
اذا وما كانوا
مهتدين الله اكبر
بسب سمع الله لمن
حمده الله الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين وهو الذي شاا
جنات
معروشات وغير
معروشات والنخل والزرع مختلفا اكله
والزيتون
والرمان
متشابها والزيتون
متشابها وغير
متشابه كلوا من ثمره اذا اثمر واتوا حقه
حصاده ولا تسرفوا انه لا يحب المسرفين
ومن الانعام
حموله
وفرشا كلوا مما رزقكم الله ولا تتبعوا
خطوات
الشيطان
انه لكم عدو مبين ثمانيه
ازواج من الضان اثنين ومن المعز اثنين قل
ان الذكرين حرمان
الانثيين اما اشتملت عليه ارحام
الانثيين نبئوني بعلم ان كنتم
صادقين ومن الابل اثنين ومن البقر ا
قل
ان الذكرين
حرم قل ان الذكرين حرما ما اشتملت عليه
ارحام
الانثيين قل
ان الذكرين حرم
الانثيين اما اشتملت عليه ارحام
الانثيين ام كنتم
شهداء اذ وصاكم الله
بهذا فمن ظلم ممن افترى على الله كذبا
ليضل الناس بغير علم ان الله لا يهدي
القوم
الظالمين قل لا اجد فيما اوحي الي محرما
على
طاعم يطعمه الا الا ان يكون ميته او
دما مسفوحا او لحم
خنزير او لحم
خنزير
فانه فسق
فانه رجس او فسق اهل لغير الله به فمن اطر
غير باغ ولا عاد فلا اثم
عليه فمن اطر فمن اطر فلا فمن اطر فلا اثم
فمن اطر غير باغ ولا عاد فلا اثم عليه ان
ربك غفور
رحيم
فمن الطر غير باار ولا عاد
فان ربك غفور رحيم وعلى الذين هادوا حرمنا
كل ذي ظفر ومن البقر والغنم حرمنا عليهم
شحومهما
حرمنا عليهم شحومهما الا ما حملت
ظهورهما الا ما حملت ظهورهما او الحوايا
او ما اختلط بعظم ذلك
جزيناهم ببغيهم
واننا
لصادقون فان كذبوك فقل ربكم ذو رحمه واسعه
ولا يرد باسه عن القوم
المجرمين وسيقول الذين اشركوا لو
شاء الله ما
اشركنا لو شاء الله ما اشركنا ولا
اباؤنا ولا حرمنا من
شيء كذلك كذب الذين من قبلهم حتى ذاقوا
باسنا
قل هل
عندكم من
علم فتخرجوه
لنا ان تتبعون الا الظن وان انتم الا
تخرصون قل فلله الحجه البالغه فلن
شاء لهداكم
اجمعين قل هل ان
شهداءكم الذين يشهدون ان الله حرم هذا فان
شهدوا فلا تشهد
معهم ولا تتبع
اهواء الذين كذبوا
باياتنا والذين لا يؤمنون
بالاخره والذين لا يؤمنون بالاخره
وهم بربهم
يعدلون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
السلام اللهم
[Silence]
يس
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
استقيم
واستو
الله
اكبر لا
الهير بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن رحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
قل تعالوا اتل ما حرم ربكم عليكم الا
تشركوا به شيئا وبالوالدين
احسانا ولا تقتلوا
اولادكم من املاق نحن نرزقكم
واياهم ولا تقربوا الفواحش ما ظهر منها
وما بطن ولا تقتلوا النفس التي حرم الله
الا
بالحق ذلكم
وصاكم به لعلكم
تعقلون ولا تقربوا مال اليتيم الا بالتي
هي احسن حتى يبلغ اشده واوفوا الكيل
والميزان
بالقسط لا نكلف نفسا الا
وسعها واذا قلت فاعدلوا ولو كان ذا قربى
وبعهد الله
اوفوا ذلكم
وصاكم به لعلكم
تذكرون
وان هذا صراطي
مستقيما فاتبعوه ولا تتبعوا السبل فتفرق
بكم عن
سبيله ذلكم وصاكم به لعلكم
تتقون ثم اتينا موسى الكتاب تماما على
الذي احسن وتفصيلا لكل
شيء وتفصيلا لكل شيء وهدى ورحمه لعلهم
بلقاء ربهم
يؤمنون وهذا كتاب
انزلناه مبارك فاتبعوه واتقوا لعلكم
ترحمون ان تقولوا انما انزل الكتاب على
طائفتين من قبلنا وان كنا عن دراستهم
لغافلين او تقولوا لو انا انزل علينا
الكتاب لكنا اهدى منهم فقد
جاءكم بينه من ربكم وهدى
ورحمه فمن اظلم ممن كذب بايات الله وصدف
عنها سنجزي الذين يصدفون عن اياتنا سوء
العذاب بما كانوا
يصدفون هل
ينظرون الا انت تاتيهم
الملائكه او ياتي ربك او ياتي بعض ايات
ربك يوم ياتي بعض ايات ربك لا ينفع نفسا
ايمانها لم تكن امنت من قبل او كسبت في
ايمانها
خيرا قل
انتظروا انا
منتظرون ان الذين فرقوا دينهم وكانوا شيعا
لست منهم في
شيء انما امرهم الى الله ثم
ينبئهم بما كانوا
يفعلون من
جاء بالحسنه فله عشر
امثالها ومن
جاء بالسيئه فلا يجزى الا مثلها وهم لا
يظلمون قل انني هداني ربي الى صراط
مستقيم دينا قيما مله ابراهيم
حنيفا وما كان من
المشركين قل ان صلاتي ونسكي ومحياي ومماتي
لله رب العالمين
لا شريك له وبذلك امرت وانا اول
المسلمين قل اغير الله ابغي ربا وهو رب كل
شيء ولا تكسب كل نفس الا
عليها ولا تزر
وازره وزر اخرى ثم الى ربكم مرجعكم
فينبئكم
بما كنتم فيه
تختلفون وهو الذي جعلكم
خلائف الارض ورفع بعضكم فوق بعض درجات
ليبلوكم فيما
اتاكم ان ربك سريع العقاب
وانه لغفور
رحيم الله
اكب سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب الع
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
الم
م
ص كتاب انزل اليك فلا يكن في صدرك حرج منه
لتنذر به وذكرى
للمؤمنين اتبعوا ما انزل اليكم من ربكم
ولا تتبعوا من دونه
اولياء قليلا ما
تذكرون وكم من قريه اهلكناها
فجاءها باسنا بيات او هم
قائلون فما كان دعواهم اذ
جاءهم باسنا الا ان قالوا ان انا كنا
ظالمين فلنسالن
الذين ارسل اليهم ولنسالن
المرسلين فلنقصن
عليهم بعلم وما كنا
غائبين والوزن يومئذ الحق فمن ثقلت
موازينه
فاولئك هم
المفلحون ومن خفت موازينه
فاولئك الذين خسروا
انفسهم بما كانوا
باياتنا
يظلمون ولقد
مكناكم في الارض وجعلنا لكم فيها معايش
قليلا ما
تشكرون ولقد خلقناكم ثم
صورناكم ثم قلنا
للملائكه اسجدوا لادم فسجدوا الا
ابليس فسجدوا الا ابليس لم يكن من
الساجدين قال ما منعك الا تسجد اذ امرتك
قال انا خير منه خلقتني من نار وخلقته من
طين قال فاهبط منها فما يكون لك ان تتكبر
فيها فاخرج انك من
الصاغرين قال انظرني الى يوم
يبعثون قال انك من
المنظرين قال فبما اغويتني
لاقعدن لهم صراطك
المستقيم ثم
لاتينهم من بين ايديهم ومن خلفهم وعن
ايمانهم وعن
شمائلهم ولا تجد اكثرهم
شاكرين قال اخرج منها
مسوما مدحورا لمن تبعك منهم
لاملان جهنم منكم
اجمعين ويا ادم اسكن انت وزوجك الجنه فكلا
من حيث شئتما ولا تقربا هذه الشجره فتكونا
من
الظالمين فازلهما الشيطان عنها فاخرجهما
مما كانا
فيه فوسوس لهما الشيطان ليبدي لهما ما
ووري عنهما من
سوءاتهما وقال ما له نهاكما ربكما عن هذه
الشجره الا ان تكونا ملكين او تكونا من
الخالدين وقاسمهما
اني لكما لمن
الناصحين فدلاهما
بغرور فلما ذاق الشجره بدت لهما
سوءاتهما وطفقا يخصفان عليهما من ورق
الجنه
وناداهما ربهما الم انهكما عن تلكما
الشجره واقل لكما ان الشيطان لكما عدو
مبين قال ربنا ظلمنا انفسنا وان لم تغفر
لنا وترحمنا
لنكونن من
الخاسرين قال اهبطوا بعضكم لبعض عدو ولكم
في الارض مستقر ومتاع الى
حين قال فيها تحيون وفيها تموتون ومنها
تخرجون يا بني ادم قد انزلنا عليكم لباسا
يواري سوءاتكم
وريشا ولباس التق هو ذلك خير ذلك من ايات
الله لعلهم
يذكرون يا بني ادم لا
يفتننكم الشيطان كما اخرج ابويكم من
الجنه كما اخرج ابويكم من الجنه ينزع
عنهما لباسهما ليريهما
سوءاتهما
انه يراكم هو وقبيله من حيث لا
ترونهم ان جعلنا الشياطين
اولياء للذين لا
يؤمنون واذا فعلوا
فاحشه قالوا وجدنا عليها
اباءنا والله امرنا بها قل ان الله لا
يامر بالفحشاء
اتقولون على الله ما لا
تعلمون قل امر ربي بالقسط واقيموا وجوهكم
عند كل مسجد وادعوه مخلصين له
الدين كما بداكم
تعودون فريقا
وفريقا حق عليهم
الضلاله انهم اتخذوا الشياطين
اولياء من دون الله
ويحسبون ويحسبون
انهم
مهتدون الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
استفر
[Silence]
بسم
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته الحمد لله والصلاه والسلام على
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وعلى اله وصحبه
اجمعين ان شاء
الله زكاه
[Silence]
الماله
‏time ابو بكر الصديق رضي الله
[Silence]
عنه
‏me
[Silence]
grow
الله سبحانه
وتالى سبحانه
وتعال
طبعا قران الله سبحانه وتعالى س واقيموا
الصلاه واتوا الزكاه صلاه
زكاه رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم
اسلام
الله سبحانه
وتالى الله سبحانه
وتالى ان الذين يكون الذهب
والفضه ولا ينفقونها في سبيل الله فبشرهم
بعذاب
الي يوم يحمى عليها في نار جهنم فتكوى بها
جباههم
وجنوبهم
وظهورهم هذا ما كنزتم لانفسكم فذوقوا ما
كنتم تكنزون الله سبحانه وتعالى
س
انديد
not
الله
[Silence]
هذا ما
لانفسكم
صل الله عليه وسلم
حث day of and she will be fire and will
be branding will be us brand their fors
their flank and
back رسول الله صل الله عليه
وسلم
[Silence]
م
نص
‏way
[Silence]
2.
2. need
need
transation
forend
incl
‏and and grandfa also supposed
to basic needs before for them before
you
give who is
to who should
asim سبحانه وتعالى
قر الله سبحانه وتعالى
س انما الصدقات
للفقراء والمساكين
والعاملين عليها والمؤلفه قلوبهم وفي
الرقاب والغارمين وفي سبيل الله وابن
السبيل فريضه من الله ان الله كان عليما
حكيما الله سبحانه وتعالى سد زكاه
[Silence]
‏rec
‏things
[Silence]
‏someone
‏of
allah
that
the of allah not the government
are one and this
next
شاء
الله شاء
[Silence]
الله
ى الله عليه
وسلم ان الصدقه لا تحل لغني ولا لذ مره
سوي
صدقه
[Silence]
‏grand
حين عبد اللهن مسعود رضي الله
عنها عبد اللهن مسعود رضي الله عنه صل
الله عليه
وسلم
[Silence]
يعني
كفر رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم
[Silence]
‏can i
from i can't one the
wasy
of
مج
don to be we
arey beh we should be do
that
so one thing cat that not be giving
from رسول الله صل الله عليه
وسلم صل الله عل
ان هذه الصدقه لا تحل لال محمدكا
صدقه
محمد محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم بن
هاشم
المطلب علي جعفر
عقيل رسول الله ى الله
وسلول الله علسلم
الحسن
الحصلى الله عليه
وسلم ان شاء
الله ‏next س ان شاء الله جزاكم الله
خير استقيم
واستو
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضال
ضالين
امين يا بني ادم خذوا زينتكم عند كل مسجد
وكلوا واشربوا ولا تسرفوا انه لا يحب
المسرفين
قل من حرم زينه الله التي اخرج لعباده
والطيبات من
الرزق قل هي للذين امنوا في الحياه الدنيا
خالصه يوم
القيامه كذلك نفصل الايات لقوم
يعلمون قل انما حرم ربي الفواحش ما ظهر
منها وما بطن والاثم والبغي بغير الحق وان
تشركوا بالله
وان تشركوا بالله ما لم ينزل به سلطانا
وان تقولوا على الله ما لا
تعلمون ولكل امه اجل فاذا
جاء اجلهم لا يستاخرون ساعه ولا
يستقدمون يا بني ادم اما ياتين انكم رسل
منكم يقصون عليكم
اياتي فمن اتقى واصلح فلا خوف عليهم ولا
هم
يحزنون والذين كذبوا
باياتنا واستكبروا عنها
اولئك اصحاب النار هم فيها
خالدون فمن اظلم من من افترى على الله
كذبا او كذب
باياته
اولئك ينالهم نصيبهم من
الكتاب حتى اذا
جاءتهم رسلنا
يتوفونهم قالوا اينما كنتم تدعون من دون
الله قالوا ضلوا
عنا وشهدوا على انفسهم انهم كانوا
كافرين قال ادخلوا في امم قد خلت من قبلكم
من الجن والانس في
النار كلما دخلت امه لعنت
اختها حتى اذا اداركوا فيها جميعا قالت
اخراهم لاولاهم رب ربنا
هؤلاء
اضلونا ربنا هؤلاء اضلونا فاتهم عذابا
ضعفا من
النار قال لكل ضعف ولكن لا
تعلمون وقالت اولاهم لاخراهم فما كان لكم
علينا من فضل فذوقوا العذاب بما ما كنتم
تكسبون ان الذين كذبوا
باياتنا واستكبروا عنها لا تفتح لهم ابواب
السماء لا تفتح لهم ابواب
السماء ولا يدخلون الجنه حتى يلج الجمل في
سم
الخياط وكذلك اجزي
الظالمين لهم من جهنم مهاد ومن وكذلك نجزي
المجرمين لهم من جهنم مهاد ومن فوقهم
غواش وكذلك نجزي
الظالمين الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر ا بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا
الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين والذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات لا
نكلف نفسا الا
وسعها
اولئك اصحاب الجنه هم فيها
خالدون ونزعنا ما في صدورهم من غل تجري من
تحتهم
الانهار وقالوا الحمد لله الذي هدانا لهذا
وما كنا لنهتدي لولا ان هدانا
الله لقد
جاءت رسل ربنا بالحق ونود ان تلكم الجنه
اورثتموها بما كنتم
تعملون ونادى اصحاب الجنه اصحاب النار ان
قد وجدنا ما وعدنا ربنا حقا فهل وجدتم ما
وعد ربكم
حقا قالوا نعم فاذن مؤذن بينهم الل لعنه
الله على
الظالمين الذين يصدون عن سبيل الله
ويبغونها عوجا وهم بالاخره
كافرون وبينهما
حجاب وعلى الاعراف رجال يعرفون كلا
بسيماهم ونادوا اصحاب الجنه ان سلام عليكم
لم يدخلوها وهم
يطمعون واذا صرفت ابصارهم
تلقاء اصحاب النار قالوا ربنا لا تجعلنا
مع القوم
الظالمين ونادى اص
الاعراف رجالا
يعرفونهم
بسيماهم قالوا ما اغنى عنكم جمعكم وما
كنتم
تستكبرون
اهؤلاء الذين اقسمتم لا ينالهم الله
برحمه ادخلوا الجنه لا خوف عليكم ولا انتم
تحزنون ونادى اصحاب النار اصحاب الجنه ان
افيضوا علينا من
الماء او مما رزقكم
الله قالوا ان الله حرمهما على
الكافرين الذين اتخذوا دينهم لهوا ولعبا
وغر تتهم الحياه الدنيا فاليوم
ننساهم كما نسوا
لقاء يومهم هذا وما كانوا
باياتنا
يجحدون ولقد
جئناهم
بكتاب فصلناه على علم هدى ورحمه لقوم
يؤمنون هل ينظرون الا
تاويله يوم ياتي تاويله يقول الذين نسوه
من قبل قد
جاءت رسل ربنا
بالحق قد
جاءت رسل ربنا بالحق فهل لنا من
شفعاء فيشفعوا لنا او نرد فنعمل غير الذي
كنا نع
قد خسروا انفسهم وضل عنهم ما كانوا
يفترون ان ربكم الله الذي خلق السماوات
والارض في سته
ايام ثم استوى على
العرش يغشي الليل النهار يطلبه حثيثا
والشمس والقمر
والنجوم مسخرات بامره الا له الخلق والامر
تبارك الله رب
العالمين ادعوا ربكم
تضرعا وخفيه انه لا يحب
المعتدين ولا تفسدوا في الارض بعد اصلاحها
ودعوه خوفا
وطمعا ان ان رحمه الله قريب من
المحسنين وهو الذي يرسل الرياح بشرا بين
يدي
رحمته حتى اذا اقلت سحابا ثقالا سقناه
لبلد ميت
فانزلنا به
الماء فاخرجنا به فاخرجنا به من ل الثمرات
كذلك نخرج الموتى لعلكم
تذكرون والبلد الطيب يخرج نباته باذن ربه
والذي خبث لا يخرج الا نكدا كذلك نصرف
الايات
لقوم
يشكرون الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
السلام
[Silence]
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
لقد ارسلنا نوحا الى قومه فقال يا قوم
اعبدوا الله ما لكم من اله غيره اني اخاف
عليكم عذاب يوم
عظيم قال الملا من قومه انا لنراك في
ضلاله وانا لنظرك من
الكاذبين
ان قال الملا من قومه انا لنراك في ضلال
مبين قال يا قوم ليس بي ضلاله
ولكني رسول من رب
العالمين ابلغكم رسالات ربي وانصح لكم
واعلم من الله ما لا
تعلمون اوعجبتم
ان
جاءكم ذكر من ربكم على رجل منكم
لينذركم ولتتم ولعلكم
ترحمون فكذبوه
فانجيناه والذين معه في الفلك واغرقنا
الذين كذبوا
باياتنا انهم كانوا قوما
عمين والى د اخاهم هى قال يا قوم اعبدوا
الله ما لكم من اله غيره افلا
تتقون قال الملا الذين كفروا من قومه انا
لنراك في سفاهه وانا لنظ من
الكاذبين قال يا قوم ليس بي سفاهه ولكني
رسول من رب
العالمين ابلغكم رسالات ربي وانا لكم ناصح
امين اوعجبتم ان
جاءكم ذكر من ربكم على رجل منكم
لينذركم واذكروا اذ جعلكم
خلفاء من بعد قوم نوح وزادكم في الخلق
بسطه فاذكروا
الاء الله لعلكم
تفلحون قالوا اجئتنا لنعبد الله وحده ونذر
ما كان يعبد
اباؤنا فاتنا بما تعدنا ان كنت من
الصادقين قال قد وقع عليكم
من ربكم رجس وغضب اتجادلونني في
اسماء
سميتموها انتم
واباؤكم ما نزل الله بها من
سلطان
فانتظروا اني معكم من
المنتظرين
فانجيناه والذين معه رحمه منا وقطعنا دابر
الذين كذبوا
باياتنا وما كانوا
مؤمنين والى ثمود اخاهم
صالحا قال يا قوم اعبدوا الله ما لكم من
اله غيره قد
جاءتكم بينه من ربكم هذه ناقه الله لكم
ايه فذروها تاكل في ارض الله ولا تمسوها
بسوء فياخذ عذاب
اليم واذكروا اذ جعلكم
خلفاء من بعد عاد وبوا في الارض تتخذون من
سهولها قصورا وتنحتون الج
بيوتا فاذكروا
الاء الله ولا تعثوا في الارض
مفسدين قال الملا الذين استكبروا من قومه
للذين استضعفوا لمن امن منهم اتعلمون ان
صالحا مرسل من
ربه قالوا انا بما ارسل به مؤمنون
قال الذين استكبروا انا بالذي
امنتم به
كافرون فعقروا الناقه وعتوا عن امر ربهم
وقالوا يا صالح ائتنا بما تعدنا ان كنت من
المرسلين فاخذتهم الرجفه فاصبحوا في دارهم
جاثمين فتولى عنهم وقال يا قوم لقد
ابلغتكم رساله ربي ونصحت لكم ونصحت لكم
ولكن لا تحبون
الناصحين ولوطا اذ قال لقومه اتاتون
الفاحشه ما سبقكم بها من احد من
العالمين انكم لتاتون الرجال شهوه من دون
النساء بل انتم قوم
مسرفون وما كان جواب قومه الا ان قالوا
اخرجوهم من قريتكم انهم اناس
يتطهرون
فانجيناه
فانجيناه واهله امراته كانت من
الغابرين وامطرنا عليهم مطرا فانظر كيف
كان عاقبه
المجرمين الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله اكبر الله
ا
الله
اكبر
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين ادنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين والى مدين اخاهم شعيبا قال يا قوم
اعبدوا الله ما لكم من اله غيره قد
جاءتكم بينه من ربكم فاوفوا الكيل
والميزان ولا تبخسوا الناس
اشياءهم ولا تفسدوا في الارض بعد
اصلاحها ذلكم خير لكم ان
كنتم
مؤمنين ولا تقعدوا بكل صراط
توعدون وتصدون عن سبيل الله من امن به
وتبغون عوجا واذكروا اذ كنتم قليلا فكثركم
وانظروا كيف كان عاقبه
المفسدين وان كان
طائفه منكم امنوا بالذي ارسل
به
وطائفه لم يؤمنوا
فاصبروا فاصبروا حتى يحكم الله بيننا وهو
خير
الحاكمين الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
‏e
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
الله اكبر الله
ا بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين الهاكم
التكاثر حتى زرتم المقابر كلا سوف تعلمون
ثم كلا سوف
تعلمون كلا لو تعلمون علم
اليقين
لترون
الجحيم ثم
لترونها عين
اليقين ثم
لتسالن يومئذ عن
النعيم الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
الله اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين والعصر ان
الانسان لفي خسر الا الذين امنوا وعملوا
الصالحات وتواصوا بالحق
وتواصوا
بالصبر الله اكبر اكبر الله
اكب سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
الله اكبر الله
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم
الضالين
امين قل هو الله احد الله الصمد لم يلد
ولم يولد ولم يكن له كفوا
احد الله
اكبر
سمع
الله لمن
حمده ربنا لك الحمد حمدا كثيرا طيبا
مباركا فيه مل السماوات والارض وملء ما
بينهما وملء ما شئت من شيء بعد اهل
الثناء والمجد احق ما قال العبد وكل نا لك
عبد اللهم لا مانع لما
اعطيت ولا معطي لما منعت ولا
راد لما
قضيت ولا ينفع ذا الجد منك الجد اللهم صل
على سيدنا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين ربنا لا تؤاخذنا ان نسينا او
اخطانا ربنا ولا تحمل علينا اصرا كما
حملته على الذين من
قبلنا ربنا ولا تحملنا ما لا طاقه لنا به
واعف عنا واغفر لنا
وارحمنا انت مولانا فانصرنا على القوم
الكافرين ربنا لا تجعلنا فتنه للقوم
الظالمين ونجنا برحمك من القوم
الكافرين ربنا اتمم لنا نورنا واغفر لنا
انك على كل شيء
قدير اللهم اقسم لنا من خشيتك ما تحول به
بيننا وبين معصيتك ومن طاعتك ما تبلغنا به
جنتك ومن اليقين ما تهون به علينا مصائب
الدنيا ومتعنا الله اللهم باسماعنا
وابصارنا وقوتنا ما
احييتنا واجعله الوارث منا واجعل ثارنا
على من ظلمنا وانصرنا على من
عادانا ولا تجعل مصيبتنا في ديننا ولا
تجعل الدنيا اكبر همنا ولا مبلغ علمنا ولا
تسلط علينا بذنوبنا من لا يخافك ولا
يرحمنا اللهم اللهم دبر لنا فانا لا نحسن
التدبير واختر لنا فانا لا نحسن الاختيار
اللهم وفقنا لخيري الدنيا
والاخره نسالك يا رب من خير ما سالك منه
نبيك محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم ونعوذ بك من
شر ما استعاذك منه نبيك محمد صلى الله
عليه وسلم اللهم بلغنا ليله القدر واجعلنا
من عتقائك من النار ومن
المقبولين اللهم انزل سكينتك ورحمتك ونصرك
ومددك وعونك على اخواننا في غزه اللهم كل
لهم عونا ونصيرا اللهم كل لهم عونا
ونصيرا اللهم اطعمهم من جو
وامنهم من خوف اللهم ارفع ايدي الظالمين
عنهم اللهم ارغم انوف
المتجبرين اللهم اذل
المستكبرين اللهم انتقم كل من كل من اعان
على عبادك ولو بشطر كلمه
اللهم عجل بنصرك لهم يا رب
العالمين لا اله الا الا انت سبحانك انا
كنا من
الظالمين وصلى الله وسلم وبارك على نبينا
محمد وعلى اله
واصحابه
اجمعين الله
اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
لا اله الا
الله
ان